en este vídeo vamos a resolver un
ejercicio sobre una valoración ácido
base para esto comenzaremos analizando
qué es lo que ocurre en la reacción de
un ácido oxálico y al entender esto
realizaremos los cálculos pertinentes
para la resolución de este ejercicio
he tomado este problema del capítulo 4
del libro química y reactividad química
de kotz dry cal y transcend y yo he
hecho con su permiso así que vamos a
hacer este ejemplo dice problema una
muestra de 1.0 34 gramos eso va a ser
importante y esta cantidad va a ser
importante de ácido oxálico en puro esto
también es importante déjame subrayar lo
lo vamos a ocupar se disuelve en agua y
se le agrega un indicador ácido base la
muestra requiere 34.47 mililitros esto
también va a ser importante de nh a 0.4
185 molar para llegar al punto de
equivalencia
es la masa del ácido oxálico y cuál es
su porcentaje de masa en la muestra eso
es lo que nos pregunta y antes de
meternos a resolver este ejercicio sería
muy bueno saber y recordar qué es lo que
está pasando tenemos un poco de ácido
oxálico que en realidad se ven como dos
ácidos carboxílicos unidos así que por
aquí los voy a poner
tenemos un carbono por aquí otro carbono
por acá y aquí tenemos una unión entre
ellos y bueno aquí tengo un doble enlace
con un oxígeno y un enlace con uno o h
esto para este carbono pero para este
pasa exactamente lo mismo aquí voy a
tener un o h mientras que por aquí tengo
un doble enlace con un oxígeno si no te
acuerdas de esto puedes ir a la lista de
vídeos de química orgánica y así podrás
aprender un poco más sobre este ácido
oxálico y aquí está tenemos un ácido
oxálico
este ha sido es bastante interesante
porque en realidad puede donar dos
ratones pueden donar dos protones es
decir este protón puede ser donado y
este protón también puede ser donado en
realidad esta molécula está estabilizada
por resonancia y si eso no te dice nada
no te preocupes aprenderás más de eso en
química orgánica lo importante es que
aquí hay dos protones que podemos
atrapar de ella
este hidrógeno de aquí y este otro
hidrógeno de aquí estos dos ahora
recuerda que cuando pones en el agua
hidróxido de sodio realmente ese
hidróxido de sodio se disuelve y da
lugar a un solo hidróxido a un solo
h negativo entonces cada molécula de
hidróxido de sodio me va a dar sólo un
hidróxido el cual solo puede atrapar a
uno de estos dos hidrógenos así que por
cada molécula que tengamos de ácido
oxálico vas a necesitar dos de estas
moléculas de hidróxido 2 hidróxidos para
atrapar estos dos protones de hidrógeno
una molécula de ellas para atrapar a
este protón de hidrógeno y otra molécula
de ellas para atrapar a este otro
hidrógeno con esta información sería
bastante bueno escribir justo acá abajo
la ecuación balanceada con la que
estamos tratando así que vamos a empezar
escribiendo este ácido oxálico que si te
das cuenta tenemos 12 hidrógenos
entonces es h 2 pero también tenemos 2
carbonos entonces h 2
2 y 1 2 3 4 oxígenos o 4 este está en
una solución acuosa y bueno a este le
voy a sumar estas moléculas de n
h es decir hidróxido de sodio de lujo
pero este hidróxido de sodio que también
está en una solución acuosa date cuenta
que para neutralizar a este que tenemos
aquí se necesitan dos moléculas de
hidróxido por lo tanto aquí le voy a
poner un 2 se necesitan dos moléculas de
este hidróxido de sodio para neutralizar
a una de estas moléculas de ácido
oxálico y una vez que esta reacción
ocurre que va a pasar
bueno puedes darte cuenta de lo
siguiente este ácido oxálico va a perder
estos dos hidrógenos se van a ir y por
lo tanto me voy a quedar solamente con
c2
4 lo cual tiene una carga de menos 2
perdió 2 protones de hidrógeno lo voy a
escribir aquí tiene una carga de 2 - y
solo para ser claro esta carga de 2 - va
aa ser atraída con estos dos odios que
me van a quedar solitos después de que
esta reacción ocurra cada uno de estos
hidróxido de sodio se va a separar en
átomos de sodio con una carga positiva y
aquí voy a tener hidróxido con carga
negativa por lo tanto aquí voy a tener
dos moléculas de sodio con carga
positiva las cuales se van a sentir
atraídas por esta molécula de aquí en a
y lo voy a poner justo aquí va a tener
una carga de dos más y bueno son dos de
ellas se van a sentir atraídas con justo
lo que sobró desde ácido oxálico así que
date cuenta que estas moléculas se van a
volver neutras son atraídas entre sí y
continúan en una sola
acuosa así que lo voy a escribir aquí ya
esto habrá que sumarle bueno pues aquí
tengo dos hidrógenos que se van a juntar
con estos hidróxidos y la forma de hacer
eso es darnos agua por lo tanto me van a
quedar dos moléculas de agua a esto les
voy a sumar dos moléculas de agua h2o
uno de estos hidrógenos viene de este
ácido oxálico y aquí tengo o h hidróxido
lo cual forma una molécula del agua y
como tengo dos hidróxidos y dos
hidrógenos me dan dos moléculas de agua
así que es hora de hacer los cálculos
para empezar tenemos 34.47 mililitros de
hidróxido de sodio así que eso sería muy
bueno en esta parte de aquí pasarlo a
litros para que sea mucho más fácil de
trabajar con nuestra concentración así
que tengo 34.47 mililitros déjame
apuntarle por aquí
a 4.47
mililitros y esto lo quiero transformar
a litros así que vamos a hacer nuestra
conversión a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por bueno arriba voy a poner un litro un
litro y yo sé que por cada litro que yo
tenga es exactamente lo mismo que tener
mil mililitros así que aquí voy a poner
mil
mililitros así que los 1000 litros y los
mililitros semana cancelar y me va a
quedar 34.47 por uno entre mil es decir
34.47 entre mil lo cual es muy fácil
solamente es cuestión de recorrer el
punto uno dos tres lugares y me va a
quedar
0.0 3 447 esto ya está en litros ahora
esta es la cantidad de litros que
nosotros tenemos de nuestro hidróxido de
sodio que por cierto tiene una
concentración de 0.4 185 molar eso
quiere decir y para eso déjame utilizar
otro color esta parte nos va a servir
0.4 cientos 85 molar su concentración
porque me está diciendo que yo tengo
cero punto 485 moles por cada litro que
yo tenga de mi solución estoy pensando
en mi hidróxido de sodio así que si lo
escribo aquí abajo
voy a poder obtener la cantidad de
moléculas con las que empecé de
hidróxido de sodio así que a esto lo voy
a multiplicar por bueno la polaridad
recuerda que es cero punto 485 molar es
lo mismo que decir que tengo cero punto
moles goles de bueno nh de hidróxido de
sodio de lujo esto por cada litro de mi
solución por cada litro de mi solución y
así este litro y este litro se va a
cancelar y solamente me va a quedar la
cantidad de moles de hidróxido de sodio
que necesite para valorar este ácido
oxálico creo que es buen momento de
sacar mi calculadora para multiplicar
estos dos así que déjame traer por acá a
mi calculadora no tengo justo por aquí
vamos a traerla y voy a multiplicar 0.03
447 a esta cantidad la voy a multiplicar
por 0 punto 485 moles que tengo por cada
litro así que en total
voy a tener cero puntos 0 16 7
de hidróxido de sodio y bueno como
estamos utilizando tres cifras
significativas lo voy a redondear a 0.01
67 así que vamos a escribirlo por aquí y
esto va a ser exactamente igual que
0.016 siete moles de n
moles
hidróxido de sodio en am
un año y es importante recordar que por
cada molécula de ácido oxálico que
nosotros tenemos necesitamos dos
moléculas de hidróxido de sodio dos
hidrógenos para que ésta se neutraliza
por lo tanto para saber la cantidad de
moles que tenemos justo de este ácido
oxálico lo que vamos a necesitar es usar
esta información
lo voy a apuntar por aquí abajo así que
dejan bajar un poco esta pantalla para
que utilicemos esa información a esto lo
voy a multiplicar lo voy a multiplicar
por la información que acabamos de
mencionar por cada dos moles moldes o
moléculas ok de hidróxido de sodio de n
h éstas van a neutralizar a un molde de
ácido oxálico así que lo pueden poner
justo por acá estas dos moléculas van a
neutralizar
mol de ácido oxálico h 2c
4 eso quiere decir que para obtener los
moles de ácido oxálico que yo tengo
justo con lo que empecé lo que necesito
es dividir esta cantidad entre 2 así que
de nuevo voy a traer por acá a mi
calculadora la tengo justo aquí y
entonces a esta cantidad habrá que
dividirla entre 2 y es me va a dar 0.008
35 etcétera y tomando tres cifras
significativas me va a quedar 0.008 35
entonces déjame apuntar eso esto me va a
dar la cantidad de moles que es 0.008 35
moles moles de justo lo que quería ácido
oxálico h 2
4 y esto está muy bien ya tenemos la
cantidad de moles de este ácido oxálico
pero qué es lo que nos preguntaban
nosotros queríamos la cantidad déjame
subir un poco en la pantalla aquí lo que
me piden es la masa del ácido oxálico y
para sacar la masa del ácido oxálico
necesito la masa molar de cada uno de
estos tres átomos que tengo aquí y bueno
para hacer un poco de memoria déjame
bajar un poco en la pantalla porque voy
a ponerte justo por aquí la masa molar
de cada uno de estos tres si tú vas a la
tabla periódica te vas a dar cuenta que
el hidrógeno y déjame ponerlo con un
color distinto el hidrógeno tiene una
masa molar una masa
molar y bueno déjame ponerlo así de un
gramo por cada 1000
gramos por cada
ahora si te fijas en el carbono bueno el
carbono tiene una masa molar de cuánto
la masa molar del carbono si te fijas en
la tabla periódica te va a decir que es
12 gramos por cada molde de carbono que
tú tengas y ahora si nos fijamos en el
oxígeno el oxígeno tiene una masa molar
modular esta es superior
su masa molar es de 16 16 gramos por
cada
ahora si te fijas en el h2
2 o 4 es decir en este ácido oxálico
tengo dos de estos hidrógenos y si a
esto lo multiplicó por un gramo por cada
mol me va a quedar 2 gramos por cada mol
eso para los hidrógenos ya esto le voy a
sumar bueno pues la masa molar de tener
2 carbonos la masa molar de tener 2
carbonos es 2 por 12 locales 24 gramos
por cada mol de lujo ya esto habrá que
sumarle bueno pues la masa molar de los
oxígenos lo cual es 16 gramos por cada
mol pero tengo 4 oxígenos así que me va
a quedar 16 por 4 los cuales 64 64
gramos por cada molde de lujo
eso quiere decir que si sumo en total
cada uno de estas masas molares de estos
átomos que conforman el ácido oxálico
voy a obtener 2 más 24 más 64 lo cual es
64 24 es lo mismo que 88 44 86 y 28 88
más 2 me va a dar 90 90 gramos por cada
mol es la masa molar de este ácido
oxálico de mi ácido oxálico con el que
empecé así que déjame escribirlo aquí su
masa molar molar va a ser de 90 gramos
por cada gol y esa información la voy a
utilizar para sacar la masa de mi ácido
oxálico con la que empecé
así que recordando que tenemos esta
cantidad de moles de ácido oxálico y ya
sabemos su masa molar pues bueno vamos a
calcular la cantidad de masa que
nosotros teníamos de ácido oxálico dejen
utilizar esta información así que justo
lo voy a apuntar por aquí tengo cero
punto 0-0 835 moles moles de bueno y
ácido oxálico déjame ponerlo así h 2c 2
4 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar lo voy a
multiplicar por la masa molar de este
ácido oxálico lo cual es 90 gramos por
cada mol por 90 gramos de bueno de h 2c
2 ó 4 por cada molde 90 gramos de este
por cada uno de los moles de este ácido
oxálico déjame apuntar la h 2c 2 o water
y con esto ya voy a obtener la primera
parte de la solución de este problema la
masa de ácido oxálico con la que empecé
así que si te das cuenta esto se va a
cancelar con esto déjame ponerlo así y
entonces me va a quedar la
multiplicación de esta cantidad por esta
así que de nuevo voy a traer por acá a
mi calculadora de lujo y habrá que
multiplicar la respuesta anterior
90 lo cual me va a dar 0 punto y como
necesito tres cifras significativas lo
voy a redondear a 0.75 2 voy a notarlo
por aquí esto me va a dar 0
punto 75 2 gramos de esto h 2c 2
4 de mi ácido oxálico y de hecho esta es
la respuesta de la primera pregunta con
la que empecé si recuerdas nos
preguntaban cuál es la masa del ácido
oxálico de nuestro ácido oxálico bueno y
hace la respuesta así que vamos a notar
nuestra respuesta nuestra respuesta es
0.75 20 punto 750 y 2 gramos de lujo y
ahora pasemos a nuestra segunda parte de
nuestra pregunta cuál es su porcentaje
de masa en la muestra total es decir en
nuestra muestra de 1.0 34 gramos de
ácido oxálico impuro y para eso lo único
que hay que hacer es dividir bueno pues
la masa que obtuvimos entre la cantidad
de masa total del ácido oxálico impuro
es decir 1.0 34 así que de nuevo voy a
sacar por acá mi calculadora y voy a
dividir esta cantidad lo que obtuvimos
entre
punto 0 34 y esto me va a dar como
respuesta 0 puntos 72 75 si lo
redondeamos me va a quedar 72 puntos 8
por ciento así que la respuesta de esta
segunda pregunta es 70 y 2.8 por ciento
ya con esto somos capaces de descifrar
que la masa del ácido oxálico es el 72.8
por ciento del ácido oxálico impuro y ya
está la respuesta de este problema nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo